well we were expecting some tension uh
today in beirut we knew this protest was
happening uh what we weren't expecting
is what ended up on the streets of
lebanon which was uh frankly worryingly
reminiscent of the worst violence in the
70s and 80s when lebanon was in the grip
of a civil war now hezbollah and their
close political allies amal party were
marching as you say in protest against
the judge who is conducting this inquiry
into the port explosion of over a year
ago nobody has been held accountable for
that yet and hezbollah
don't like this judge they feel he's
asking too many awkward questions and
trying to get to the top of lebanon's
political echelon
they were met that is hezbollah
at a crossroads effectively between
two districts
in lebanon by sniper fire coming from
buildings and what ensued was then a gun
battle between the two sides that lasted
for a number of hours civilians caught
in the middle of it children in a nearby
school told to lie down flat on their
faces hands above their heads in order
to be protected
and it was only really once the lebanese
armed forces moved in that khan was
eventually restored but as i say you
know incredibly worrying scenes for
lebanon particularly in the context of
what is going on in the country it is
facing one of the worst financial crises
in modern history
hyperinflation on a par with zimbabwe
and weimar germany it is that bad there
is a shortage of fuel people queue for
hours in order to fill up their cars
there is a shortage of basics like
medicine
and food
the new government that has only just
come into power is very fragile it will
be slum what teetering as a result of
events from today and uh the only thing
that really has not happened so far in
lebanon's collapse is a deterioration in
any significant terms in the security
situation we've seen street protests uh
most nights actually if you're in beirut
but they're small scale they're people
burning tires and pieces of wood
blocking off streets nothing like this
and so the question really this evening
is will this escalate further is it the
start of something more
will lebanon descend into violence or
will khan be restored